the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right so let's get started so today
or last lecture we talked about
different device parameters mainly our
series resistance and shunt resistance
and how that affects our efficiencies
today we're going to talk a lot about
different material properties and how
they affect certain device
characteristics and mainly just affect
our output efficiency so we've been
talking a lot about the fundamentals I'm
sure you guys are loving this right now
so we're gonna complete this in probably
the next three lectures and then move on
to a lot of the kind of cross-cutting
themes in PV some advanced concepts you
know different device architectures and
that kind of thing and so that is coming
in the future but we're still doing
fundamentals today and so I know you're
probably all aware of this equation and
again this is kind of the progress we've
made so we're almost all the way through
explaining basic device physics and
basic semiconductor physics too so you
can understand simple devices and it's
always important to remember that your
device is like a leaky bucket and you're
limited by the largest hole in that
bucket so the weakest aspect of your
solar cell is really what's going to
limit your device performance and
especially if any of you here are trying
to make devices it's really important to
think about all of these things when
building it and this is very difficult
to do I can certainly tell you that okay
so I kind of like this slide what this
is is saying what's the thing we care
about most in our solar cells well as
scientists other than dollars per watt
we want to maximize our efficiency for a
certain price and our efficiency there
are several parameters that go into it
again we talked about our JSC our
short-circuit current our open circuit
voltage and our fill factor and that
gives us our output energy or output
power and we divide that by the input
power which is the solar insolation now
we can split up that again in the open
circuit voltage short circuit current
and fill factor we talked a little bit
last lecture about fill factor and how
that's influenced by
different resistive losses in our solar
cell today we're gonna mainly be focused
on short circuit current and things like
internal quantum efficiency which are
highly affected by our diffusion length
and the diffusion length is often
limited by certain defects in our
materials and we're gonna get into why
that is and to a certain extent we'll
talk about open circuit voltage because
your JSC can really has a large effect
on your open circuit voltage so what
we're gonna learn today is what is
minority carrier diffusion length it was
in the homework hopefully you guys have
some idea coming to lecture but today
we're gonna talk about a little more in
depth and why it's important and how
it's affected what are the parameters
that determine it so mainly diffusivity
and lifetime we're gonna describe how
it's actually measured in a solar cell
there's actually really cool measurement
and we actually have the capabilities in
our lab and possibly some of you when
you're making cells will be able to do
that measurement we're also going to
look at some of the things that live at
lifetime to some of the basic
recombination mechanisms also look at
how your excess carrier concentration
changes as a function of lifetime and
generation light and then also talk
about the last material parameter which
is mobility which discusses kind of how
well these excited charges can move
around within your material so without
further ado your minority carrier
diffusion length definition is really
simple if you generate let's say a
photon comes and hits a silicon atom and
generates
an electron pair over here how far or
how much volume can it explore that
volume it can explore is described by
some characteristic radius and that
radius is known as the diffusion length
and it's really important to solar cells
because when you think about these
carriers that you're generating when
they if they can only explore a very
short area they're not going to make it
this is a very good solar cell so the
diffusion length is really long and all
these carriers generated there we'll be
able to make our Junction so again just
so we're familiar this is our base and a
top we have our our emitter so our the
junction would be at this line right
here on that plane
if we have a really bad solar cell so
let's say a lot of defects present a lot
of areas for these excited carriers to
recombine they won't make it to the
junction they'll have a very short
diffusion length and as a result your
short-circuit current and your vo si
will suffer dramatically so it's really
important to get good crystal quality
and good material quality but up to a
certain point right there's kind of
diminishing returns as you go to higher
and higher qualities and we'll talk
about that in a second so if we assume
what this is showing is how our short
circuit current scales with our
diffusion length so we have some
something called the generation rate and
this is often proportional to the photon
flux on your material so the number of
photons hitting your solar cell and this
generation rate is something the number
of carriers produced a second in some
given volume so it's a volumetric term
and if we assume that everything within
one diffusion length of our Junction
gets collected that'll all be counted as
short-circuit current so you basically
your JSC has this kind of linear
dependence on your diffusion length but
that's only true up to a certain point
right so if for example if we have a
diffusion length that's much longer than
the device thickness it's really not
going to get again diminishing returns
as you go to longer and longer diffusion
lengths so this is a calculation I did
using a 1d simulation program called PC
1d which if you want to play around with
it's free
it's a lot of fun to use actually and
you can put in things like lifetimes and
I very basically the lifetime which
we'll get to in a second how that
changes the diffusion length and you can
see that there actually is a linear
relation until the diffusion length is
about on the order of 300 microns which
is the device thickness so you can see
this kind of trailing off and become sub
linear in its response yeah
so let's let's let's think about it one
step back why do we care about minority
carriers right so if let's say you
generate an electron hole pair and
n-type material the hole wants to move
to the p-type side right and it's the
electric field will actually repel and
keep it on the electron on the on the on
the n-type side so it's your minority
carriers that matter in terms of the
separation and we'll talk about that
again if that's still fuzzy in people's
heads and so what carrier what matters
in terms of you talking about deriving
the ideal diode equation well yeah but
in order to be separated which is the
first part that we care about we it
matters that it's reached the junction
and so it's that concentration at the
junction that determines the flux across
the junction so make sense okay okay and
so there's also this other loose
dependence on vo C on your diffusion
length and so if you recall from a few
lectures ago this is your the equation
for vo C is dependent on your
short-circuit current temperature and
your saturation current which you can
also often think of as your reverse bias
current and your saturation current is
dependent on your diffusion length JSC
if you've recall was linearly
proportional to the diffusion length so
the vo C actually scales with the
natural log of the square of the
diffusion length and if you pull out
that exponent it just squares with the
natural log of your diffusion length and
again very very simple analogy we're
assuming again that fill factor is not
really affected by your diffusion length
and that your efficiency is proportional
to the product of your JSC and your vo C
so your short circuit current your open
circuit voltage and you can see as you
go to longer diffusion lengths there's
this area of diminishing return and
again there's two different regimes here
one is when your diffusion length is
again much less than your device
thickness you can see that uses a huge
increase in efficiency but as your
diffusion leaks gets well well above
your device thickness that becomes less
and less important okay so how do you
deal with this so if you have let's say
suppose you want to make a really cheap
solar cell and you have a very dirty
material with very short lifetime shown
here there's kind of several ideas of
what you can do you can have a very very
thin device now that's a problem if you
can't absorb it very well so you can
have some kind of optical tricks you can
do surface texturing there's all sorts
of other ideas for basically having the
carriers come in at angles or having a
good reflector on the back so that's
ways you can with you can work with very
low diffusion length materials and still
get a device efficiency that's not not
too bad okay now we're going to talk
quickly about how our minority carrier
diffusion length is measured and again
this is something we're able to do in
our lab and one of the important things
to say is define is collection
probability so for example if this is
our junction right here or our space
charge region if you generate a carrier
let's say very very close to the
junction it's going to have a high or
near Unity probability of making it to
the direction and being collected if
it's generated very very very far away
it's going to have a lower probability
and that's what this graph is trying to
show is that right near the junction you
have near Unity collection probability
and as you go away it comes down and the
different colored lines are showing kind
of different ways of increasing that
diffusion length surface passivation is
important we'll talk about what that is
soon and also diffusion lengths you if
you're limited by
fusion length you can see this very very
sharp drop-off right here it's
technically defined as reaching the
junction and being separated which in
essence will hopefully be the same thing
yeah it can it can affect the diffusion
length and will or the effective
diffusion might we'll get to that in a
second it'll be a bit later this is kind
of just showing that there's a lot of
different material parameters not just
your diffusion length that can really
affect your device performance in your
collection probability Oh so if you
recall a few slides back we said that
our short-circuit current was directly
proportional to our diffusion length and
the reason is that if you're generating
carriers within the diffusion length you
generally think of that as the region of
which you're actually collecting those
carriers right and if you go back to the
next slide that kind of makes sense and
so this is highlighted so this is our
junction here we have our n-type
material on top our p-type below and
within a diffusion length of your
minority carrier so on your p-type side
you hear about the diffusion length of
your electrons and the n-type side you
care about the diffusion length of your
holes and that's the region where you're
really collecting carriers of course
there's like a tail off but the first
order approximation this is actually a
very good one and so now putting those
all together if we know how our carriers
are generated as a function of X and we
know what the collection probability is
as a function of X based on diffusion
length surface passivation and other
parameters we can multiply them and then
integrate to actually get what our
illuminated current will be
the emitter hmm for most models you
pretty much assume that anything
absorbed I mean first of all the space
charge region is very very narrow
it's almost assumed just to be
negligibly thin and the emitter is
generally very very short and the
diffusion lengths are so poor in the
emitter for reasons we'll get to soon
that it's almost a dead layer your
response at the very short wavelengths
where you're absorbing most your light
in the emitter generally don't add to
your short-circuit current and we'll
talk about that soon so excellent
question
yeah wait sorry say that again so for
certain wavelengths of light let's say
that are this out this curve this is for
kind of representing beer Lambert's law
if it attenuates less drastically that
characteristic absorption length if it's
a lot longer than this length here then
yes you can assume that this emitter
region is negligibly thin and that's a
little bit what the homework goes over
as well in problem 3 excellent question
and so what we care about is kind of the
spectral response of our short-circuit
current so what what this is is this is
a quantum efficiency tool this is
something we have in our lab it's a
really fun tool to play around with how
it works is you basically have let's say
we have a light source that's white
light and it goes through a series of
filters there's a monochromator which
basically it diffracts the light so it
spatially separates the light kind of
like a rainbow and then you can focus
that on to your solar cell and measure
the current output and under short
circuit conditions and that will tell
you because you know the carrier
generation profile for different
wavelengths of light because you know
what alpha is for silicon you can
actually pretty well calculate what what
your diffusion length is and we'll talk
about that on the next slide so this is
kind of what your quantum efficiency
walk like this is I think
actually don't know this is
internal-external but they're just
related by a factor of one over R so
here your blue response so everything
that's absorbed right in the near
surface region in your emitter generally
doesn't get collected and this is due to
really bad diffusion links in the
emitter region as you go to longer
wavelengths which are due the absorption
length is much much deeper you're
collecting a lot of it and then what do
you think is happening here you're
generally these longer wavelengths your
alpha is is so low that you're not
actually absorbing much of this light
which is part of the reason that you're
not collecting it or that you're
absorbing it so far away from the
junction that it's not being able to
diffuse there and so that's kind of how
you can look at these quantum efficiency
curves and it's this region here that's
really limited by diffusion lengths and
again you have a homework problem
discussing how that's done some of the
cool other tools I lab can kind of do
this but it requires a little more
I don't know handwork on the operator
but if you can take different eqe curves
or iqe curves at different points on
your solar cell and you get those
spectrums you'll get a whole bunch of
different spectrum you'll scan with your
your light beam you can actually get the
fusion lines as a function of position
and get a spatial map of your different
diffusion lengths and it's really
helpful if you're trying to find spatial
inhomogeneities in your cell so I
believe that this is some multi
crystalline cell and you see all sorts
of grain boundaries and those are areas
of very short diffusion length and we'll
talk about why that's the case
actually on the next couple slides
question yeah
so you're okay so alpha is what tells
you is your absorption coefficient right
and it's often in units of one over
centimeters so inverse centimeters and
so if you plot what that looks like it's
some exponential function with X right
and the point two which is attenuated by
a factor of one over EE
that point is one over alpha and that's
often called the absorption depth or am
I thinking of absorption length of that
wavelength and alpha will vary as a
function of wavelength if you recall
that if you look at lambda for silicon
it's something that continues to go down
at longer wavelengths so the short
wavelengths are absorbed very strongly
and so most of the light is absorbed
very very close to the surface where the
longer wavelengths most of the light is
actually absorbed better they're far
from the surface that make sense and so
there's a difference between your
absorption length and your diffusion
length and that ratio is what's really
important right if you're absorbing
really far away from the junction but
you have a long diffusion length there's
a greater chance of it making there and
it's that ratio that's really really
important does that answer your question
okay so what limits is minority carrier
diffusion length we're gonna get to the
equation a second for the minority
carrier diffusion length but basically
when you excite an electron hole pair
you have this mobile electron and it's
in this excited state you've given it
this energy from a photon and now can
move around and it can only exist for a
certain amount of time before it finds
another hole and recombine and that
event again is called recombination and
a lot of this is actually determined by
the size of grain
in your material if you've seen think on
the the cell that Tonio brought in
earlier
sorry I don't have a good example it
didn't just look like one kind of flat
plane you could see like different grain
orientations and the edges of those
grains are called grain boundaries and
those can act as kind of recombination
centers and actually reduce your that's
called your lifetime which we're gonna
get to on this slide okay so this slide
has a lot of stuff going on what it's
saying is that your diffusion length is
characteristic of the diffusivity the
product the square root of the product
of your diffusivity in your lifetime the
way I like to think of diffusivity is
that you have it goes up with
temperature and it's also affected by
your mobility the mobility is saying
that if you apply let's say an external
field an electric field how well can
those electrons move around so we're
really high mobility means that those
electrons can move really easily and
you'll accelerate them really quickly
we're very low mobility means that
they're gonna continue to hit into
things and bump around and not move
around too well and your diffusion is
this kind of thermal process if you
think of let's say gases in a room and
you have a hot gas that's going to
diffuse a lot faster so it's the product
of these two things it's it's kind of
how well it can move around times it's
kind of thermal energy that it has to
move around the energy it has for moving
and so that's kind of what the
diffusivity means to me the life time
again is what I mentioned earlier is
that when you create this excited
electron that's now free to move this
mobile electron it can move around in
explore a certain area that area or
sorry volume is defined by the diffusion
length and it exists in that excited
state for some amount of time tau and
that tau is not you know the not every
carrier that's generated necessarily has
that lifetime but it's a characteristic
lifetime that it could have oh yeah and
then they're pointed out here what they
are
okay so that's what affects our
diffusion like so in the next bunch of
slides we're going to talk about mainly
how we can affect tau so tau is mainly
affected by recombination centers so
defects and semiconductors and a few
other things that we're going to talk
about and then this is almost kind of
limited depending on what kind of
materials you're using the mobility and
so we'll talk about that as well so all
right what effects lifetime we're gonna
go over again basic recombination
mechanisms and semiconductors there's a
lot of them a lot of them have some
rather complex kind of equations behind
them we're not gonna delve too deeply
into how to derive them you're welcome
to do that it was actually kind of fun
to do on my own and refresh myself so
it's really useful and also be able to
calculate our excess carrier
concentration which we're gonna do in
the next couple slides so okay and let's
say for p-type material or sorry n-type
material the number of mobile electrons
you have is defined as N and not is very
frequently your dopant density so these
come up with 1/2 the time sorry wrong
direction are generally the doping
concentration right so if you're putting
in phosphorous atoms into your silicon
it would be the concentration of
phosphorous atoms your Delta n is how
many extra electrons are you adding
mobile electrons due to the photo
excitation of light right and so that's
what this is saying is that you have
some your Delta n is equal to your
generation rate so your generation rate
is generally in units of carriers per
volume per second so how many carriers
you're generating in a certain volume
and because Delta n is actually a
density you need to say okay how long do
those carriers last once they're excited
and so is this GTL product is what gives
you your Delta n now when working with
silicon it's really important to
understand what the different ratios are
of N and not Delta n your doping
concentrations so getting these relative
numbers in your head is an important
step in moving forward so
let's say we subject a piece of silicon
to am 1.5 spectra yeah so you're G oh
sorry this is a little off there we go
sorry about that when I added some
equations so your your generation rate
is on the order of 10 to the 16 a
carrier lifetime for silicon this is not
a great lifetime but in okay one is
about 10 microseconds and so as a result
of that you'll get about 10 to the 11
carrier excess carriers per centimeter
cubed and if we can't compare that so
for every excess electron we make
remember we also leave behind a hole so
we have a delta n is generally equal to
Delta P and that's about ten to the
eleventh if we look at our intrinsic
carrier concentration so if we had no
dopants how many carriers would we have
just for the thermal excitation and
that's about ten to the ten and so you
can see that your Delta n is actually
larger than your intrinsic carrier
concentration for silicon under normal
illumination conditions now let's take
an example suppose we add phosphorus at
the order of about 10 to the 16 so
that's generally about what a base
doping concentration should be in that
realm might be a little high but you can
see that your while your Delta P is much
greater than P naught so P naught would
be how many holes do you have which is a
ratio of your intrinsic carrier squared
over your dopant density and that's
about 10 to the fourth so it's way way
less then your then what was there
without excitation right so the number
of holes without any light shining on as
P naught you generate a bunch of holes
Delta P by shining light on it and you
can see that these numbers are
drastically different and of course your
dopant density is actually much much
larger than your Delta n so that on your
majority carriers don't change very much
but your minority carriers change very
very drastically that's really what this
is trying to say here under excitation
okay what is lifetime all right so I
hope that bubble shouldn't be up yet
okay so we measure tau by creating some
excess carrier population and then watch
them decay and they decay at some rate
recombination rate and under steady
state conditions so under a constant
elimination if we're not looking at
transients your recombination rate is
actually equal to your generation rate
so if you compare the two equations on
the previous slide they're true under
steady state conditions so that's my
public and so your lifetimes will add up
like parallel resistors so we have tau
bulk which is kind of the effective
lifetime of these photo excited carriers
and it's equal to this the 1 over tau
bulk is equal to 1 over tau radiative so
this is radiative recombination and this
has to do with basically if you read the
shockley-queisser efficiency limit paper
this is the lifetime that they assumed
was limiting and for silicon this is
observed like that this is never ever
the limiting factor and a lot of direct
band act materials for those of you
don't know what that is don't worry
about it that's often the limiting
factor and it has to do with the
absorption is always equal to the
emissivity in a material for a direct
bandgap material radiative recombination
can be an issue right and I'll talk
about that in a second
and there's also another recombination
called O'Shay recombination it's not
audre like I thought when I first came
here is O'Shea kind of like I don't know
Oh Jay Simpson I guess and its dominant
only under very high injection
conditions or very high doping density
so in your emitter layer where there's
really really high doping densities
you're going to have a lot of Roche
recombination and the last one is
shockley-read-hall so these are three
guys they came up with this kind of
model for how recombination happens in
defective material so materials with
levels
electronic levels in the mid gap and
again these add like parallel resistors
so you're always so if you remember back
to the the leaky bucket these are your
leaky buckets for diffusion length right
you're always limited by your shortest
diffusion length or sorry your shortest
lifetime and this is often your limiting
lifetime is your shock would be a hog
recombination okay silicon okay so
radiative recombination so you can
probably guess from the name that
radiative recombination involves the
photon the ability to absorb photons
also means you have the ability to emit
them and so silicon or many
semiconductors will emit photons when
you get a recombination event across the
band and when that happens you emit a
photon under equilibrium conditions so
equilibrium means no outside excitation
doesn't mean steady-state so this is
let's say in the dark you get your
recombination rate is equal to your
generation right right because it's in
thermal equilibrium with the area around
it so it's absorbing photons and
emitting them at the same rate and this
is equal to B so some material parameter
times your hole and electron
concentration and again under
equilibrium conditions that's equal to
your intrinsic carrier concentration
right your NP product is equal to NI
square now when you shine light on it
your n which is equal to there we go
and naught plus Delta n so this is your
excited carrier so your excess carriers
so your n now increases and is greater
than n sub I and your net recombination
rate is determined by this equation
right here so BN P minus B ni square so
the difference between your equilibrium
and your now excited carrier
concentrations it's a material parameter
yeah it depends on for silicon I forget
what's on the next slide it's 10 to the
minus 15 I don't know for other
materials but I presume that that would
change
probably be a lot higher for other
materials and it turns out your
radiative recombination lifetimes when
you plug these numbers in and you make
some assumptions about what's really
small compared to each other you get
these equations here and again this is
tau is equal to Delta n over R and so
you get that and now if you look at it
for silicon you get B is about two times
ten to the minus fifteen your Delta n I
put or sorry yeah and I determined just
was 10 to the 16 some doping
concentration and your radiative
lifetime is incredibly incredibly long
about 50 milliseconds and if you
remember from before when I was
calculating a generation rate for
silicon we used about 10 microseconds so
this is really really long and so radio
recombination is very very slow and it's
rarely ever the limiting lifetime in
silicon based solar cells however as as
you mentioned earlier it's actually a
big problem in direct bandgap materials
and if you think of there are some
materials who actually want a very short
radiative recombination time so for
example if you're trying to make an LED
you inject carriers using a voltage that
recombination emits photons and then you
get light and that's basically how an
LED works so okay so now we'll talk
about a little bit shockley-read-hall
recombination so this is something that
our lab works I think very very well in
we do a lot of like defects and
semiconductors specifically iron and so
iron is one of these really really awful
contaminants and solar cells just a
little bit of iron I think Tony Craig
Miller I think I don't remember what
year production this was maybe it was
2009 but 2 grams of iron could
contaminate the entire year supply of
silicon detrimental e so that's a lot
yes you do for a single panel and you'll
it shocked me anyhow so basically we're
trying to say here is that you have iron
atoms and it can sit in different areas
of your lattice but you have these
defects that
exist and they introduce different
energy levels within the bandgap right
so the outer electrons of iron can
either sit at these sites so these blue
sites were their donors or they can
create acceptor States kind of like
boron does but they're much higher up
into the gap and these act as
recombination centers and we'll talk
about why that is in a second
so these trap levels can interact with
mobile carriers in a whole bunch of
different ways okay it can capture an
electron that electron can then sit
there if there's enough heat energy it
might actually get promoted and jump out
of that and then which case it wouldn't
have actually decreased your excess
carrier population it can also capture
holes and they can also emit holes and
there's a bunch of things that go into
these equations here it depends on a lot
of the energy of this trap state it
depends on the carrier excitation we'll
talk about that another few slides and
it also depends on these kind of what
are like effective I forget the exact
word of the effective hole and electron
lifetimes and those are limited by your
trap density so these are can be thought
of suppose that each let's say each iron
atom is introducing one trap level it
would be the number of trap levels the
density of trap levels within your
system times some thermal energy so and
then a capture cross section which is
saying okay that trap state exists in
one location kind of how much area can
it see in terms of what effective area
is at capturing electrons and and
oftentimes at an under the right
conditions so with very very deep traps
so traps mid gap under low injections
your shocker recall recombination is
actually one of those two lifetimes and
it's a very simple equation in under
very very high injection conditions it's
actually summing them up and if you look
in the previous slide if you go to Delta
n goes to infinity you can see that this
becomes true
that's a good question that would be my
guess
yeah sorry there's another question back
there or like I can Hank so then it is
iron it were stupid or worse still Oh in
terms of capture cross-section yeah I
know they're both bad really bad i Tonio
do you know that off the top your head
I'm sure so gold is gold has a larger
life ending at that lower concentration
since iron it's perhaps one of the worst
and that's why you're not allowed to
wear old jewelry leaders they ask you to
take off your high end ears okay so no
bling in the cleaner there you go
and so for the material scientists and
physicists in the room if that does not
apply to you don't worry this is just to
explain what's going on
often when you want recombination to it
happen so this is a momentum or K versus
energy it requires not only the emission
of a photon but also a phonon to change
its momentum when you introduce a trap
level are these localized impurities
because it's localized in real space its
delocalized in k space so you have this
kind of flat level and k and you have
these very very efficient pathways for
recombination if that doesn't resonate
with you don't worry about it right now
so okay so here we see that really the
impurities can have a very very large
effect if you think of the doping
densities that we put in we've been
using about 10 to the 15 10 to the 16
for our dopant densities this is on the
order of like a million less and it can
have a huge impact on lifetime so one of
the worst again as we said was ion and
these interstitial irons are especially
bad and that tend to the I don't know it
looks like 10 to the 11
very very low concentrations that's one
in 10 to the 12 so that's one in a
trillion atoms or iron can detrimental
impact your solar cell so that's really
really bad so keeping fabs clean so
again no jewelry and other things can
really that can actually have a very
large effect on your device performance
and if you plot that versus your
dislocation density you can see that if
you have it's especially bad for very
very high lifetime silicon just a few
dislocations can actually really really
hurt it but the effect is mitigated if
you're already starting with very low
lifetime so again and again this is
something our lab works on quite
extensively is it's not just the number
of iron atoms so if you take a piece of
silicon and you want to know its
lifetime or how iron impacts is lifetime
it's not just a total number of iron
atoms in it it's also how they're
distributed so if you have let's say
clusters of iron atoms that would count
as one defect or effectively less than
the number of atoms in it and so
clustering these things can actually be
really really a good way of cleaning up
your your solar cell material and this
is an effect called gettering and if you
can kind of get are these impurity atoms
into one location they'll have less of a
detrimental impact on your material so
this is kind of a tricky one to explain
but this is a so shockley-read-hall
recombination can also show up in
something called surface recombination
so if you look at your silicon lattice
each silicon atom has four valence
electrons and it bonds to four silicon
atoms around it and it has satisfied
covalent bonds so this silicon atom has
all its bond satisfied all its bonds
satisfied until you get to the surface
and at the surface you have what are
called dangling bonds and these dangling
bonds can actually introduce trap States
and you can see that it actually
introduces a whole ton of levels within
the bandgap that can provide
shockley-read-hall recombination
pathways for your carriers means the
surfaces are incredibly important
and the way we tend to think of it and
this is kind of a concept that might be
difficult to grasp at first but it
scales with two things there's two
things going on you can think of that
this is the width of your cell and you
have some surface recombination velocity
which is some kind of characteristic of
how well they can recombine at the
surface
and let's say infinite surface
recombination velocities it means that
any carrier that comes and hits that
surface will most surely recombine so
this drops to zero so then you're
limited by okay how well can they
actually diffuse to your surface so it's
it's again some kind of ratio of your
cell thickness squared over the
diffusivity or carrier diffusivity and
that that gives you an idea of what your
limiting factors are so under very low
surface recombination velocities you're
limited by this term here the first one
and under very high ones you're limited
by this term and so there's two kind of
effects going on there and it's
summarized as well here it at at very
very low service recombination
velocities your house surfaces almost
goes to infinity very high and you can
passivate these bonds using hydrogen so
for example if you use hydrofluoric acid
what it does is it edges away the
silicon oxide layer that sits there and
you have these hydrogen atoms then now
sit and satisfy these bombs and if
they're perfectly satisfied you'll have
a mobile carrier it'll actually
elastically scattered off not lose any
energy and not recombine through these
trap States yeah
what is if you if you actually I've seen
some diagrams of what silicon oxide
looks like on silicon it passivates many
of the bonds you're absolutely right HF
is actually probably the best the
problem is that it etches glass and
other things that are in your solar cell
material and it's incredibly dangerous
it can kill you rather dramatically so
it's only used in laboratory settings if
you're trying to actually take lifetime
measurements and negate the effect of
surface recombination silicon oxide can
be a good one if you actually look at
the structure there's a few dangling
bonds within there but it can passivate
most of them just not all of them
another good passivation technique is
actually the silicon nitride AARC coding
it passivates the surface very well so
yeah good question and there's other
ways to mitigate surface recombination
so we'll talk about that I think in
either next lecture or the one after
that so so yeah this slide is just
telling us that if we bury our thickness
of our silicon we can actually measure
our service recombination velocity and
we can fit it so we can figure out our
tau surface which is really important
material parameter generally I think
good surface recombination velocities or
anywhere from like 10 to maybe in the
hundreds for centimeters per second and
really bad ones are much much higher
okay and the last type of recombination
mechanism we're gonna talk about today
is o.j recombination and this looks like
when I first saw this I'm like why on
earth would this ever happen and the
fact is it doesn't until you get to very
very high carrier concentrations so you
can see that it involves three particles
let's say an n-type silicon it needs two
electrons and a hole what happens is is
that you get the simultaneous relaxation
and excitation so you get this
relaxation of this excited electron into
a hole and then you get this
excitation of this other electron into a
higher energy state and then it thermal
ices down in releases of phonon releases
heat yeah Jessica so this is going to be
our n-type material and again because
this type of recombination event
requires two particles it requires two
electrons so it's N squared in one hole
so the recombination rate goes up with P
N squared at high enough concentrations
and so your towel goes up with the one
over N squared and this is particularly
bad again only at very because it goes
up with a square of the carrier
concentration it's really bad at a very
high carrier concentration so if we look
at this plot we can see that our
minority carrier lifetime drops well
below a microsecond around 10 to the 18
so you generally want to stay out of
that range of doping concentrations in
your base because you'll have very very
bad lifetimes
sorry this is our didn't label this
you're right this is the valence band
that's the conduction band okay all
right and so this is kind of driving
home again that leaky bucket idea is
that you're really limited by your worst
lifetime and so if you remember what
we're thinking about parallel circuits
here your bulk or your effective
lifetime of each carrier is determined
by these three here your radiative sorry
that should be a band which is the same
as your radiative recombination O'Shay
in chocolate Reed Hall and so in
different excess carrier densities so
we're varying Delta n by shining various
intensities of light and we can kind of
activate different limiting lifetimes so
it very low you're a limited by
shockley-read-hall and Chakra Greenhalgh
can actually go down with higher
illumination conditions and your O'Shay
remember against really really bad
around 10 to the 18 becomes your
limiting so your tell bulk is always
doing is never doing better than your
worst lifetime hello Jay this came out
of Dana MacDonald's thesis talam it er
is it's complicated because it has other
influences in it Oh Jay I always think
of recombination in the emitter is Oh
Jay but you also have other carriers
coming in due to injection currents
right or and so your excess carrier
population is also a function of that
and so the equation for it gets a little
more complicated but it would make sense
that as you increase illumination you're
increasing your your current into the
emitter and you would get more carriers
and it would decrease and it looks
almost exactly like Oh Jay in this in
this regime over here I'm not sure the
other things that go into it but if you
look up as theses I think it gives a
pretty good description okay so you're
probably bored of hearing me say this
but again it's we're always limited by
our weakest so in defect mitigated
recombination material so we're
the your shortest lifetime is due to
some kind of shockley-read-hall
recombination it's always your lifetime
for shockley-read-hall is always going
to be much much shorter than your
radiative lifetimes which is a
characteristic we can exploit for
measuring the lifetimes of our materials
so because very very few carriers will
actually radiatively recombine and emit
a photon that if more of them are ready
to leak recombining then we know that
it's a very high lifetime material if
there's a lot of defects and we have
very very short lifetimes very few of
them will radiatively recombine and so
this emission of photons with energy at
the bandgap it can kind of give us an
idea of the lifetime within our material
and that's how we measure it's a
technique called photo luminescence and
what you do is you shine light on it
generally with a laser we put a diffuser
in front of the laser so the laser beam
spreads its photons over a large area we
excite all these carriers so this laser
has very very short wavelengths and I
think in our very short it's 900
nanometers
silicon's bandgap corresponds to about
1108 nanometers and so 900 is easily
absorbed not just right near the emitter
but also somewhat well deep into the
below the junction as well and then as
we begin to see recombination when
radiative recombination happens we emit
a photon and that can happen in certain
areas better than others and it a lot of
it depends on like I said defect density
and other lifetime limiting defects and
it's a good way to kind of like
spatially locate where problems are in
your solar cell any other questions that
it depends on your camera right so we
use I think a germanium camera to detect
those photons because silicon won't have
a very good response and yeah it depends
on the CCD array within your camera it
can be really good I do a similar
technique to measure shunts and we have
a microscope objective we just have to
zoom in really really far and then we
just scan over an area okay and last
little thing is that if you recall let
me this slide traps can not only trap an
electron but you can also emit an
electron assuming it has enough thermal
energy and you can see that on this plot
and so this is an Arrhenius plot so
again
high temperatures aren't this direction
low temperature over here and you can
see that your lifetime actually
increases at higher temperatures because
electrons that see that trap fall into
it then can easily come back out of it
because they have enough thermal energy
to escape and that's really what this is
depicting so what one of the things I
think for researchers in the room who
are studying these types of materials
varying temperature is often a really
really good way of looking at electronic
structure of materials and it can be
very very powerful and this is one
example of a tool to look at this kind
of these types of traps okay oh good we
have plenty of time we actually might
end early
okay so now we're going to talk about
mobility we've given a lot of sorry
that's that's a good question so
phosphorus actually has if you draw it
on an E versus X diagram so if we have
our conduction band here our valence
band here we said iron put states in the
middle of the gap phosphorus and boron
actually put States very very very close
to the valence band conduction band if
you go to low enough temperature so
let's say you know below 100 Kelvin you
can actually freeze out those donor
electrons onto the phosphorous atoms and
below certain concentrations of
phosphorus atoms for example so below
like 10 to the 18 at 0 Kelvin you cannot
conduct electricity it actually becomes
a total insulator this is an excellent
question but at room temperature when
Katy is on the order so Katy is your
thermal energy and at room temperature
if you put that 4 electrons
it's 0.026 electron volts or 26 milli
electron volts this is a good number to
have in mind by the way when that number
is on the order of this binding energy
for phosphorous they're almost always
fully ionized and free but that's a very
good question
alright alright so if we remember our
definition of mobility it's related to
our diffusivity and again our mobility
is saying how well these excited charges
can move around and it's also related
how much thermal energy these charges
have so that's why we have this KB T
factor and what's plotted on the right
is the Shocker quasar efficiency limit
which are those stars and then how if
you let's say you reduce your mobility
by let's say a factor of 10 or 100
what's the impact on the overall
efficiency and you can see that if you
detrimental impacts your mobility you
can really have a large effect on your
diffusion length and it can really hurt
your device performance so it's really
important material parameter to think
about okay so there's lots of ways that
these mobile electrons can do what's
called scattering so if I'm mobile
electron I'm moving down through the
silicon lattice and let's say I see a
defect and this defect because it has
these extra electrons it creates this
kind of area of charge it can see that
it can scatter off of it and lose its
energy and so that's called a scattering
event and that can well not really lose
its energy sorry it'll change direction
it kind of impacts the the movement of
that carrier and there's all sorts of
other defects scattering mechanisms you
can also scatter with an oscillating
atom or a phonon that's another type of
scattering mechanism and it's heavily
dependent on what you put into your
material and we'll talk about that in a
second
and for a lot of materials that are
let's say porous or amorphous in some
way or even a lot of like let's say
organic semiconductors having a good
percolation Network is really important
to transport these charges and often
it's a very limiting factor and let's
say like organic photovoltaics so this
is a relatively simple scattering
mechanism we appointed himself
what's going on here is that we can see
that as we add carriers so this is and
it's ten to the 14th very very low
concentration of dopants as we increase
the number of carriers are scattering
off of those ionized impurities so every
time you add a phosphorus atom let's say
you introduce a static positive charge
and a mobile negative charge when that
electron leaves and so you now have all
of these scattering centers of positive
charge and so as you increase the number
of dopants this is for silicon you
decrease the mobility of your of your
material and it's also greatly a
function of temperature I think that's
mostly due to either phonon scattering
that right there's there any other
mechanism I'm missing Tonio
but importantly is that higher
temperatures you may generally get a
much lower lower mobility and again
hitting home for this is not sure
necessarily for silicon but for a lot of
like these hetero Junction devices so
for example organics have very very low
diffusion lengths and a lot of it's
limited by mobility and so what you do
is you make these inter digitated P or P
I what I would call PN and I forget the
exact analogy but P and n layers that
inter digitated so that they only have
to diffuse not the width of the device
but the length of those fingers so you
effectively need a much shorter
diffusion length and so this is talking
about some of those other different
ideas and a hetero Junction is two
different materials
that's an inter digitated p.m. structure
yeah so what we're gonna be talking
about is kind of the products of N and
mu and if you recall that your
conductivity so hold on let's go back
what we have here is that we have a
highly doped semiconductor so this is
about 10 to the 16 and then we have our
intrinsic silicon so this has no dopants
in it whatsoever and now you remember
from last lecture when we applied a
voltage across the terminals a current
started to flow and when we heat it up
what had happened your members current
increased and that's due to more
thermally excited carriers and so you're
injured intrinsic carrier concentration
goes up right and so your inch what was
for room temperature what's the
intrinsic carrier concentration it's
about 10 to the 10 and that range and so
an increase a small increase in
temperature can greatly increase the
intrinsic carrier concentration may be
something like 10 to the 12 now in a
dope semiconductor is that going to
affect it as much how about you guys
think about that for a little bit
meet and talk to your neighbor and so
I'm going to keep both of these up along
with a high doping concentration and one
with a low and which one do you think
will have the highest relative change in
conductivity and in which direction so
I'll give you three minutes
okay so we're now going to subject
you've seen this demo before we're now
going to subject our intrinsic carrier
to my hairdryer and right now we're
getting let's see it's about 10 micro
amps and if we heat this guy out
then mix these two look ah there we go
okay so you can see we get a rather
large increase in kind that was up to a
hundred micro so a factor of ten so
quite a large increase okay so let's see
a show of hands so right now we're
getting maybe we need to put this on
milliamps yeah so we're getting about
fifty eight milliamps of current through
the semiconductor who thinks that the
currents gonna increase when we add more
thermal carriers this is for the doped
one we just saw the intrinsic yeah yeah
what do you think it'll go up the
conductivity so this is for the dope
semiconductor now who thinks it's gonna
stay the same
who thinks is gonna go down all right so
this is split Wow alright so right now
we're getting about 57 milliamps and
let's heat this guy up and see what
happens as you can see it's actually
going down it's now 52 50 49 so what's
important is that we're measuring
conductivity it's not only how many
carriers we have but also how well they
can move around and it's again that
product of number of carriers comes with
mobility and again each of those
carriers carries an electric charge so
we put the electric charge of an
electron in front of it oh this is what
I'm supposed to have up in the
background while that was happening yeah
so again remember there was huge changes
one was measuring milliamps one was
measuring micro amps so if we look at
room temperature we have about ten to
the ten intrinsic carriers right so this
is for intrinsic silicon with no dopants
whatsoever as we increase the heat even
when I don't think we're getting to 500
degrees but let's say we get to 400
we're only going up by a factor of a
hundred which is substantial right but
if we had 10 to the 16 carriers
originally from our dopants these added
number of intrinsic carrier's aren't
going to have really much of an effect
at all in terms of the conductivity so
what's really affecting the doped case
is that our mobility actually goes to
with temperature due to these scattering
events with temperature and for
intrinsic silicon you get a little bit
better mobility so it's a little bit
higher but they both have the same
general trend of lower mobility but only
by let's say this is about a factor of
10 where it was about a factor of
hundred for the for the intrinsic
carrier so again our carriers and the
intrinsic case go up by a factor of 100
our mobility goes up by a factor of 10
so the conductivity then has to increase
by a factor of 10 and for our dope
semiconductor really the heat is just
hurting our conductivity because of the
decrease in mobility and the thermal
carriers don't really add they're washed
out by the the sea of doping atoms that
are really adding all the carriers
would you ever want your solar cell that
hot that's a big question so let's go
there's an equation for that and we'll
talk about that later too okay so if you
look at our vo see if we have a large
saturation current that means that we're
gonna have a very low vo C right we have
this reverse current that's going in the
opposite direction of our illumination
current that's opposing that
illumination current and so if it's
large then it'll hurt our vo C and you
can see that it scales with D which
scales with KT and so we get this
increase in temperature is increasing
this J naught and so for most types of
cells heat is very very bad especially
for crystalline silicon for amorphous
silicon that's different well I'm not
gonna get into that today but for a
crystalline silicon it's it's heat is
generally very bad for the performance
and when you do testing so for example
when NREL does tensing they'll rate all
your cells at you know am 1.5 g some
calibrated solar simulator that's you
know illuminating your sample and
they're kept at constant temperature so
the temperatures always reported and
it's generally kept at 25 C so the
temperatures are very important
characteristic but to answer your
question if again we looked at an
Arrhenius plot so this is 1 over KT so
this is high temperatures over here low
temperatures over here and this is
carrier concentration at very very high
temperatures the when when your thermal
carrier so if you extend this out to
higher temperature you can see that this
will actually surpass the number of
dopant atoms and you'll actually
increase so this is high temperature
over here
your carrier concentration will actually
increase at much much lower sorry much
much higher temperatures and this is
what's the extrinsic region so your
donor concentration is pretty much only
determined by your dopant density so
this is MD and then at low enough
temperature so this is very low
temperatures you actually start freezing
out your donor electrons into these
donor states so that actually sums it up
if you guys have other questions feel
free to ask them but we actually can end
a little bit early I do have your
homework so if you want those come up
here and I think Tonio posted the
projects online so you can finish
homework number three that's it
you